maybe maddie you know we were supposed
to have you early
wasn't he on the books and then
something what what happened
we were whatever on the books i was
going to change the flight and then i
just didn't come
and i just didn't come why did you come
country's trash
and then i was like i can just keep
making money in my own country so do you
even have a capital in your country
ottawa does it they have a capital there
yeah
right yes we do what does that
insurrection look like uh
it's just it's just a bunch of white
people with powdered wigs
walking around women eyes to the ground
hanging out pamphlets
yeah that's very um so maddie you live
in canada i have to say about canada
though
is you guys are just so annoyingly nice
it's just it's like annoying we're nicer
than you
me you people americans yeah yeah yeah
you guys are annoyingly nice um you guys
are annoyingly
talented it's like annoying michael j
fox
canadian kim kerry jim carrey but what
about the music
ah do you know hip hop arcade fire okay
is it an arcade fire canadian yeah if
you're a white college student [ __ ]
you maddie matt pon pierre is chad
kroger
um canada yeah van van van city baby
yeah
yeah party nickelback style yeah yeah
you guys have really good talent up
there celine dion
never heard of her oh yeah she's new
she's she's great she's great
one of the best vocal you know she's
done well for herself very well um
she's no whitney though she's now she's
true
i would say she's definitely on par
you think that she's on par with whitney
how many whitney houston songs can you
say like the names of and how many
celine dion songs can you say you only
know that
everyone just knows the titanic song i
don't know any of them i have celine's
greatest hits
and there's like thirty-six start at two
and maybe i can finish it oh my god
okay hang on celine there were nights
when though
um let me see you know the titanic just
go ahead
titanic yeah everybody
james cameron yeah anyway that's great
so you literally
he's canadian isn't it cameron canadian
it is from chippewa damn it oh my god
which is right by where i live in
ridgeway wait wait you have directors
from there too
we have directors oh my guy jake
gyllenhaal
holy holy [ __ ] i want to come in my
mouth he's from winnipeg i want him to
come with my mom justin bieber
pamela anderson pam god bless pam yeah
no way sandra in my eyes sandra oh oh
she is sandra oh
yeah sandra oh is from there oh you know
what grace park
grace park do you know who she is korean
yes
[Applause]
she's been on korean
battle sarge yeah exactly do you ever
see that did you ever see that
i don't watch tv i know but you usually
never saw it no
i okay can i just ever talked about
battlestar galactica on the show have
you
heard no six thousand dollars george and
you're i just want to say i just want to
say your vast name i want to say this
though
if you've never seen that battle circle
actor first of all it's a pretty much
all canadian class
it's based on scientology no it's not oh
they had the pot [ __ ]
the pot-faced mexican guy on it what's
his name edward edward james almost
yeah yeah yeah so maddie um when did you
start
um cooking oh so
you know i had this really good i
understand my mother used to make bread
every morning
stand under him that flower used to fly
yeah i'd look up and be like one day i'm
going to be a chef yeah do tons of
cocaine and kill myself
it was just like you know i just i saw
everything i did
all right i'm i'm not asking for the
origin story of [ __ ] maddie okay
when i just want to know i just because
i don't know if the [ __ ] world
thousands i think two thousand
in two thousand how old were you i was
uh not eight
i went to cooking school yeah so you
went to
why did you go to cooking school because
i didn't get accepted to any other
colleges
i'm an idiot but you're driven i'm a
bare minimum student
yeah you know just to get by yeah no
punk on the
fat chubby you know black-haired nail
polish
yeah society yeah yeah yeah yeah pops
[ __ ] josh
[ __ ] everybody yeah you know just i was
you know you and i are similar in that
way like i just in high school i was
like i remember waking up going um i
have no future
yeah zero there's no fear i don't
there's no hope no
what am i gonna do i have no skill
whatsoever
and so then you kind of go up you get
kicked out of the house eventually yeah
and then you have to figure it out but i
guess we're similar in that way
we're outsiders you think so i think so
i think we're just natural
disruptors disruptors disruptors
so you were rebellious as a young you
know just punk straight up all right
like what kind of punk did you listen to
you know bad brains and crowmags and
madball hardcore
mostly hardcore yeah you know yeah to be
honest
not too punk because i got into music
through metal
oh you liked a medal i was a metal i was
a young metal head i was a very young
metal head into like deicide and
obituary and
yeah that kind of stuff